you're 22 years old but you are old
enough to know better so i will say
you're 22. i
killed it enough the hotel did have my
phone
the hotel did i end up having my phone
mia poncetto the 22 year old woman who
went
viral after she falsely accused a black
teenage boy of stealing her phone at a
hotel in new york city
snaps at gail king during an interview
with cbs
this morning okay so basically
i'm i'm a 22 year old girl i am
i i don't i racism uh
is i said i how is one girl
accusing a guy
about a phone a crime
in a virtual interview that took place
hours before she was arrested in
california
poncetto straight up snapped at the
journalist
hand in the air and all you're 22 years
old but you are old enough to know
better so i will say you're 22. i
killed it enough but before we dive into
all that
let me get you up to speed on december
26
pancetta was seen on camera approaching
a black teenager and his dad
jazz musician keon harold in the lobby
of nyc's arlo hotel
that's mine are you kidding me you feel
like there's only one
one iphone made in the world no okay
then show me this no you get to get a
life
poncetto accused the 14 year old boy
keon harold jr of stealing her phone
ultimately tackling him in an attempt to
get the phone
let me note that later her phone was
found at the hotel
harold captured the alleged assault in a
one-minute video and the whole thing was
also documented on the hotel's
surveillance camera
no i'm not letting him walk away with my
phone
harold claims his son was the victim of
racial profiling
and harassment now back to that
interview
i admit yes i could have approached the
situation differently or maybe not
yelled at him like that
and made him feel you know maybe some
sort of uh
inferior way making him feel as if i was
like hurting his feelings because that's
not my intention i consider myself to be
super sweet
on thursday poncetto and her lawyer sat
down with king for a zoom interview and
she claimed she never meant to hurt the
teen or his father
i don't feel that that is who i am as a
person i don't feel like this one
mistake does define me but
i do sincerely from the bottom of my
heart apologize that if i made
the son feel as if i assaulted him or if
i hurt his feelings poncetto also
accused the musician
of assaulting her end of the day the dad
did end up
like slamming me to the ground and
pulling my hair
and throwing me and dragging me across
the ground so
i i will say that when king pressed her
to admit her alleged actions were wrong
poncetto did this you're 22 years old
but you are old enough to know better
so i will say you're 22. i killed it
enough
the hotel did have my phone the hotel
did i end up having my phone
please note ponsetto's lawyer giving her
the old hush
hush enough the hotel did have my phone
poncedo was arrested thursday in
california by the new york city police
department
i'm not sure you're helping yourself
here and when e.t asked her attorney
about the interview
she explained quote in 20 years of legal
practice
frankly i have not encountered something
this way in the sense that i started to
question her well-being and i am
genuinely concerned for her mental
health at this point
i told her to stop i was adamant i was
stern and she was making me feel
uncomfortable and everyone else feel
uncomfortable and it was enough
her attorney revealed that she stormed
out after the interview
and has not been in contact with her
since yesterday
quote i have a client that is not
adhering to the advice that i am giving
them
it makes it difficult for me to move
forward it's a very sad story
though really it's a very sad story
something sad about her
and the fact that the trauma that she
put fourteen that's fourteen
teenagers that's not okay
you